نعتقد حقًا أنه في المستقبل
ستبني الروبوتات والطائرات بدون طيار
مدنًا وأحياء بأكملها ، كما تعلمون ،
هناك شيء ما يحدث
ويطلق عليه الناس بشكل مختلف أزمة الإسكان العالمية
ويشعرني أنه سيتعين
علينا القيام بأشياء مختلفة
قائمة على أوستن
تتعاون icon مع lennar لبناء مجتمع مكون من 100
منزل مطبوع ثلاثي الأبعاد ، وهو أكبر
حي من نوعه في
العالم ، سيختبر المشروع كيف
يمكن توسيع نطاق التكنولوجيا ، لقد طورنا
نظام طباعة محمول ثلاثي الأبعاد ، لذا فإن الطريقة التي
تبدو بها أشياء مثل  مصنع المنزل الذي
يأتي إليك ، لذلك نقوم بشحن الطابعة إلى
الموقع الذي يطبع فيه المنزل ، ثم
ينتقل إلى الموقع التالي أو يمكن لروبوت فولكان الخاص بأيقونة العمل أن
يطبع جدرانًا خرسانية ثلاثية الأبعاد
طبقة تلو الأخرى لتشكيل الطابق الأول
من المنزل بشكل تقليدي هذا
العملية عندما تفكر في
عزل الحوائط الجافة لواضعي الإطارات ، فهذه
عملية يمكن أن تستغرق من ثلاثة إلى ثمانية
أسابيع بالإضافة إلى أننا قادرون على تكثيفها
في أسبوع واحد وغالبًا ما يتم توفيرها
منتج etter في العملية وفقًا للأيقونة ، تتطلب
الطابعة
أربعة فنيين فقط للتشغيل
وتكلف العملية حوالي 20 إلى 30 بالمائة
أقل من منازل البناء التقليدية
في مجتمع أوستن التي بدأت عند
450.000
وتراوحت من 900 إلى 2000 قدم مربع
نظام الجدار الذي  هو ما نطبعه ثلاثي الأبعاد
هو الجزء الأكثر شاقة من حيث التجارة
المكلفة ويستغرق وقتًا
طويلاً من عملية البناء بأكملها ،
لذلك عندما يمكنك استبدال
الصفقات المتعددة
وسلاسل توريد المواد المتعددة بأتمتة واحدة
قوية جدًا
ولكن المنزل أكثر من مجرد
جدران  أنت تقوم بطباعة جدران ثلاثية الأبعاد ولكن
عليك إنهاء المنزل ،
فأنت بحاجة إلى أدوات مساعدة تحتاجها لوضع
سقف على جدرانك المطبوعة ثلاثية الأبعاد في النهاية ،
ربما نصل في النهاية إلى طباعة المزيد من المكونات ثلاثية الأبعاد ،
لكن في الوقت الحالي نحن مجرد
بنية طباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد  Belinda carr هي
خبيرة إنشاءات تنشئ
مقاطع فيديو على YouTube حول بناء العلوم
لإثارة حماسة الأشخاص بشأن التكنولوجيا الجديدة التي
يحاول الأشخاص وضعها في الاعتبار  في الصندوق الذي
يجعل المستثمرين متحمسين ، فإنه يثير حماس
عامة الناس ، لذلك إذا كنت تدعي
أن الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد تتسبب في التشرد بالكامل
أو يمكنها
إيقاف تغير المناخ وتساعد
البيئة أو يمكن أن تجعل الإسكان في
متناول الجميع ، فهذه مشكلات
حقيقية يواجهها الناس ولكننا لا نفعل ذلك.  لا أعرف
ما إذا كان ذلك سيحل ما إذا كان
سيحل تلك المشكلات لأنه
لا يزال ما رأته
لمجتمع الأيقونات يعد
بمنازل الأيقونات التي زرتها في أوستن والتي
كانت اندماجًا رائعًا لمجال التكنولوجيا
و  المهندسون ومجال البناء
، الأشخاص
الذين لديهم عمالة ماهرة يشاركون في
مواقع العمل الإنشائية ، لقد تقدموا في
السن خارج العالم أولاً ثم
تقاعدوا ولا يوجد عدد كافٍ من الشباب ليحلوا محلهم ،
هناك هذا
النداء للطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد  عندما تكون في
جانب البرنامج أو كنت عاملًا ،
فأنت لا تقوم بالفعل ببناء الجدران
بنفسك ، فأنت لا تصب الخرسانة ،
فما الذي يتطلبه الأمر للحصول على طباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
للمنزل  لتصبح أكثر شيوعًا في الوقت
الحالي ، لا تزال الطابعات والخلطات
مملوكة لكنني أعتقد أن الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد يمكن أن
تكون منافسًا جيدًا ، فنحن بحاجة إلى المزيد من
الخيارات ، ولا تزال هذه
تقنية جديدة جدًا يزيد عمرها عن ثلاث سنوات
بقليل ، لذا احصل على مثل أي
التكنولوجيا المبكرة للسيارات المبكرة لا
يزال هناك الكثير من اكتشاف كيفية
جعلها تعمل وتعمل لفترة
طويلة وأعتقد
أن هذا يجعلني متفائلًا بالمستقبل